was bringt eine mutter dazu fünf ihrer
kinder umzubringen
ja dass man muss man sagen man kann
etwas zum motiv sagen aber es gibt dafür
keine rechtfertigung ein motives zwei
einer erklärung aus sicht der täterinnen
aber es ist keine keine rechtfertigung
eine wirkliche erklärung gibt es dafür
nicht und ich würde auch fast so weit
gehen zu sagen dass sie nicht nur fünf
kinder getötet hat sondern sechs denn
der sohn der elfjährige sohn überlebt
hat der ist auch für sein leben
gezeichnet und man kann ihnen nur immer
nur die kraft wünschen dass er das
irgendwie übersteht und aus seinem leben
etwas machen kann
zum motiv muss oder kann man in diesen
fällen sagen prinzipiell unterscheidet
man drei kategorien neo nati zieht ist
wenn mütter ganz junge kinder innerhalb
der ersten 24 stunden töten in phan thi
zieht es wenn mütter die kinder im
ersten lebensjahr töten und vieles ist
wenn sie ihre kinder nach dem ersten
lebensjahr so ältere kinder töten warum
ist es wichtig diese kategorien
auseinanderzuhalten
ich muss überlegen wie ich das in einem
satz formulieren kann ohne sozusagen von
den wissenschaftlichen fakten
abzuweichen ich würde es so formulieren
je näher das töten eines kindes an der
geburt liegt desto größer ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass das was mit der
geburt an sich zu tun hat das heißt die
kinder sind ungewollt es ist wie eine
abtreibung nur eben nach der geburt was
dann natürlich ein tötungsdelikt oder
wahrscheinlich auch mord ist das heißt
bei ganz neu geborenen wenn mütter dann
das kind gar nicht annehmen sich nicht
darum kümmern oder töten als oft damit
zu tun dass das kind ungewollt ist oder
dass sie den partner bestrafen wollen
oder solche dinge je älter die kinder
sind desto mehr muss man nach anderen
motiven nach anderen ursachen suchen bei
einem acht oder elfjährigen kind jedes
nicht mehr darum dass das kind ungewollt
ist sondern es muss irgendeine andere
auslösende oftmals lebenskrise geben die
dazu führt wenn man sich diese fälle
anschaut in denen mütter ihre älteren
über ein jahr alten kinder umbringen
dann gibt es einiges was man über die
motive oder kategorien sagen kann
manchmal sind täterinnen psychotisch
also haben haben schwere psychische
erkrankungen manchmal ist fraglich
inwiefern sie überhaupt schuldfähig sind
wenn sie schuldig sind wenn sie genau
wissen was sie tun
dann geht es manchmal um rache am ex
partner um zu zeigen was du mir angetan
hast oder auch wenn väter kinder töten
geht es manchmal darum sich auf diese
art an der mutter seiner ex partnerin
sozusagen zu rächen manchmal sterben
kinder aus vernachlässigung ist wird
sich nicht um sie gekümmert aber häufig
und gerade in dieser kategorie von
täterinnen merkt man häufig und man
nennt das auch altruistischen vieli
zieht und das geht in 50 bis 60 der
fälle auch mit einem suizidversuch
einher das bedeutet mütter sind in einer
lebenskrise sehen keinen ausweg mehr und
sie bringen sich selbst um das ist
sozusagen das motiv für ihren suizid
oder zumindest selbstmordversuch die
frage ist warum töten sie die kinder
oftmals ist es so dass diese täterinnen
das sind keine psychopathen ohne
gewissen die es durchaus auch gibt
sondern die haben durchaus einen
gewissen aber sie reden sich selbst ein
dass das in ordnung ist dass es im
besten sinne dass das für die kinder ist
sie tun es quasi aus liebe aus ihrer
perspektive es ist die kinder nicht ohne
mutter weiterleben müssen im grunde um
es in einem satz zu packen es ist ein
bisschen diese diese diese art des
denkens ich lass doch meine kinder nicht
in dieser grausamen welt alleine denn
offensichtlich sieht sie diese welt ja
als so grausam und so und lebenswert
dass sie diese welt verlassen will und
sie nimmt dann ihre kinder mit weil sie
oft also ich man kann nicht ohne mit ihr
gesprochen zu haben was über das motiv
sagen aber typischerweise und wenn man
sich vergangene fälle und
wissenschaftliche daten anschaut über
mütter die so etwas tun dann sieht man
es oft die erklärung ist 'ich lass doch
meine kinder nicht allein was absurd ist
aber es ist ein bisschen zumindest eine
erklärung oder ein erklärungsversuch was
in dem kopf solcher täterinnen vorgeht
ja wir gerade gehört nach den neuesten
erkenntnissen haben die kinder keine
offensichtlichen verletzungen bei der
obduktion soll sich jetzt heraus schauen
ob sie vergiftet worden sind zeigt das
dass diese tat doch schon länger geplant
war oder dass ihre kinder tatsächlich
ihm nicht wehtun wollte was sagt das
über die mutter aus wenn sie die kinder
vergiftet und nicht durch verletzungen
umbringt es ist kein klischee sondern
tatsächlich war dass frauen häufiger als
männer mit den leisen morton töten also
vergiften ertrinken erstickenden die
unblutigen die leisen worten sind bei
frauen häufiger an zu finden und auch
bei bei viele zieht denn wenn mütter
ihre kinder töten ist dass häufig der
fall was die ursache dafür ist da gibt
es viele diskussionen das würde eine
eigene sendung füllen es hat
teilweise damit zu tun gerade wenn
mütter keine gewissenlosen monster sind
sondern einen gewissen haben und sich
das irgendwie schön reden es ist ja im
besten sinne für meine kinder ich will
meine kinder nicht allein lassen
ich will meine kinder nicht in dieser
schrecklichen welt lassen das heißt
gerade wenn sie keine keine
psychopathischen monster sind dann ist
es natürlich ungleich schwieriger leute
mit einem messer zu töten was anfiel
eine vielen nähere und direktere art zu
töten ist als beispielsweise durch gift
oder oder gasgrill in der wohnung haben
wir auch schon gehört und es gibt viele
fälle wo das wo das so passiert das
heißt das ist eine indirekte art eine
leisere art und manchmal für personen
emotional noch noch besser zu
verarbeiten
in diesem fall kann man zum motiv noch
nichts sagen weil einfach in dem fall
noch nicht genug informationen da sind
aber ich will was sagen zum typischen
profil solcher mütter wohlbemerkt das
sind daten aus vielen verschiedenen
fällen auf der ganzen welt teilweise
auch in den usa und das sind sozusagen
meter studien wissenschaftliche meter
studien die quasi alle fälle die bekannt
sind betrachten und daraus eine art
durchschnitts profil machen
ich will dass einmal durchgehen und ich
sehe einige punkte die hier zu treffen
aber auch einige die nicht zutreffen und
einige bei denen ich keine ahnung habe
ob sie zu treffen also es ist kein
psychogramm zu ihr wenn sie so wollen
sondern eher das durchschnittliche
psychogramm und man muss schauen was
davon zu trifft häufig sind mütter die
diese taten begehen ende 20 das trifft
in jedem fall so sie kommen oft aus
ärmeren verhältnissen haben selbst
gewalt oder missbrauchserfahrung häufig
findet man depressionen oder selbstmord
tendenzen sehr typisch ist auch dass sie
kurz vorher eine trennung durch leben
also die amerikaner sagen experience
rejection bei mayweather also
zurückweisung durch einen männlichen
partner oder ex-partner sie hat mal auf
facebook gepostet der mann ist weg und
jetzt auch noch die wohnung gebrannt das
kommt aber aus 2014 das heißt das
scheint hier nicht aber wir haben auch
gerade von dem polizeieinsatz gehört wo
es auch um die gedanken gingen damals
bei dem vater der jüngeren kinder also
anscheinend doch auch probleme in der
beziehung mit dem partner absolut aber
die trennung liegt schon länger zurück
also die trennung scheint hier zumindest
nicht der direkte auslöser zu sein
sie nutzen eher die leisen more taten
manchmal findet man ebenfalls drogen
oder alkoholmissbrauch typischerweise
sehen sie die kinder wie eine art
erweiterung von sich selbst sie sehen
die kinder
nicht als getrennte individuen sondern
im grunde vermischen sie ihr eigenes
selbstbild und ihre persönlichkeit mit
den kindern das heißt wenn sie geht dass
die kinder mit kommen ist dann sozusagen
gar keine gar keine frage oft sozial
isoliert wenig kontakte das gilt für die
kinder und auch die mütter keine hilfe
von außen alleinerziehend und in 50 bis
60 prozent der fälle geht der philly
zieht der mord an den kindern mit suizid
oder einem suizidversuch einher
wenn ich dieses typische profil mir
anschaue was der aktuelle stand der
forschung ist dann sehe ich einige
punkte die zu treffen
zu vielen kann man noch nicht sagen und
man muss natürlich auch erstmal mit ihr
sprechen und ihr auch die chance geben
das zu erklären und auch die frage
stellen ob sie überhaupt diese gedanken
nicht geschildert habe ob sie die
bewusst getroffen hat oder ob es andere
psychische erkrankungen gibt und ob sie
überhaupt schuldfähig ist und inwiefern
sie das reflektiert hat das gilt es noch
abzuwarten und der pressesprecher der
polizei hat ja auch gesagt dass man erst
mal mit ihr sprechen muss bevor man hier
valide was zum motiv sagen kann wenn wir
aber von diesem generellen bild ausgehen
der elfjährige sohn der älteste hat
überlebt sie hat ihnen den zug gesetzt
zur oma geschickt damit sein leben
sozusagen doch noch gerettet oder
verschont ist das auch etwas was in
diesen fällen öfter vorkommt dass ein
kind dann doch überlebt weil die mutter
dort dann das kind selber rettet 1
zurückzieht den versuch es umzubringen
ist das etwas was oft passiert wenn erst
mal passieren diese fälle sowieso nicht
oft und gerade wenn es dann noch um
mehrere kinder gebt passiert was noch
seltener
und deswegen kann man da selbst wenn es
ein oder zwei fälle gibt kann man kann
man nicht sagen ob das typisch oder
nicht typisch ist weil dazu zu wenig
bekannt ist man muss auch dazu sagen
dass in der polizei in der
kriminalstatistik wird oftmals nur
angegeben ob es ein
verwandtschaftsverhältnis gibt oder
nicht aber es wird nicht mal angegeben
ob es die eltern oder der mutter wer der
vater ist das heißt über diese art von
tötungsdelikten gibt es manchmal zu
wenig informationen um überhaupt sagen
zu können was der typisch ist und was
nicht das was ich genannt habe
ende 20 alleinerziehend tiefe
lebenskrise wollen die kinder beschützen
vor dieser schlimmen welt das ist etwas
was man was man sagen kann weil es da
genug informationen gibt ob es aber
typisch ist dass das ältere kinder leben
bleiben das kann ich so kann ich so
nicht beantworten